for loops you can run the same code
multiple times using a loop
the most common loop in javascript is
called a for loop because it runs for a
specific number of times here is the
structure of the for loop we also
thought for and then you're going to
have something in these parentheses you
usually have three items
there's the initialization and then you
could have semicolon then you have the
condition and then a semicolon and then
the final expression and then the
whatever is going to run in the for loop
would be in these curly braces over here
now all of these things are optional but
you have them in most four loops the
initialization is run just once to set
up the loop variable and every time the
loop is run the condition statement is
evaluated at the beginning the loop
keeps going until the condition is false
and then the final expression is
evaluated at the end of each loop
iteration and is usually used to
increment or decrement your loop counter
let me give you an example of this so in
this example first outside of the for
loop we're going to create an array
called our array and set it to an empty
array now we have the for loop this is
the initialization we are going to
create the variable I and set that I
equal to zero now here's the condition I
is less than five so we are going to
keep running the for loop while I is
less than five so as long as I is less
than five we'll continue running this
for loop at the end of each run of the
loop we are going to increment I I plus
plus just means we're going to add one
to I so it's going to go through the
loop the first time it's going to run
this code within the brackets and it's
going to push I on to the the array and
run our eye starts off with zero at zero
it's going to push zero on to the array
and then it's going to increment I
remember it does this F n so now is one
it's going to go through is going to
push one onto the array it's going to go
through push to push three push for
after four will increment I to five
before the for loop goes it's going to
check is I less than five no I actually
five I
not less than five so it's going only
going to put push the number zero
through four on to the array let's check
it out by console that logging in so
yeah we got the array 0 1 2 3 4 you can
also use a break statement to break out
of a loop early so now I have if I is
more than 2 break so if we run that it's
just going to put 0 1 2 because after 2
I is more than 2 so it breaks out of the
loop and then we're done with the loop
now it's also common for loops to
iterate through an array so if an array
already exists and has some items in it
we can loop through and cancel that log
or print out each item in that array so
we're going to initialize I to equals 0
if I is less than our dot length so
that's the array and length is the
length of the array so if I is less than
the length of the array we are going to
continue going through the array so once
we get to the end of the array we'll be
done with the for loop at the end we're
going to increment I by 1 and we're just
going to cancel that log R and then we
just put the I variable as the index
that will of the array that we're trying
to cancel that log so the first one we
get the array index 0 because I will
equal 0 and X 0 B 10 then we'll do index
1 2 3 4 because each run through the
array we're going to increment I 1 up 1
and that's going to go to the next index
of the array if we run that C but we got
10 9 8 7 6 if you have a
multi-dimensional array you can use
nested for loops to loop through both
the array and any sub arrays let me show
you an example of that ok so let's look
at this we have this array variable
which is a nested array so here's just
there's one array there's the beginning
the rain there's the end of the array
and inside the array are three other
arrays so inside the first rate here is
index 0 here's and next one
one here's index two and in each of
those indexes is another array so we
have index 0 and index 1 and each array
so you can use nested for-loops to loop
through these both arrays here's your
first for loop here's the end of that
and then here's our nested for loop so
we're going to initialize I to 0 if I is
less than or a dot length and the length
of the array see we have 1 2 3 so the
length of the array is 3 but now inside
the nested for loop we have to
initialize the variable differently so
now it's at I we have J now if J is less
than array index I dot length when we're
looking at the array index I dot length
that's the first item in the array which
is the first array within the array so
now the length of this is just 2 we have
1 2 so we're going to end then we're
going to increment J so we're going to
run through this first floor loop and
inside the first for loop we're
basically going to go into the first
array and now we're going to count
without lock each item in the first
array we're going to array index I index
J so the first index is what index in
this first array which which would be
for going to X 0 that's this and then
the index J will be what index in the
second array in the nested array so we
would get in X 0 and X 1 for J it's
going to go through this inner for loop
to get both and that is in the first
array then it's going to go back to the
outer for loop to bump up to this next
array and then we're going to go through
the inner for loop again to get both
indexes in here and so on if we log if
we console that log that it's going to
say 10 9 8 7 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 so the first
2 9 8 7 6 was from up here and then we
have the 1 2 3 4 5 6 from down here well
those are four loops and nested
for-loops thanks for watching my name is
beau Carnes don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your coach we're good